you guys ready for this no boy it ain't
over
democrat house judiciary chairman calls
for doj to conduct federal review of
written house verdict he wants federal
charges which i do not see happening
this is probably just you know show
boating or you know saber rattling from
timcast.com cassandra fairbanks i
believe cassandra yep rights
democrat jerry nadler is calling for the
department of justice to conduct a
federal review of the verdict in the
written house case tweeting this is
heart
this heartbreaking verdict is a
miscarriage of justice and such a
dangerous precedent which justifies
federal review by doj justice cannot
tolerate armed persons crossing state
lines looking for trouble while people
engage in first amendment protected
protests sue this man for defamation
please please no armed person crossed
state lines dominic black was indicted
by is being charged by the d.a for the
straw purchase in providing the rifle to
kyle written house in wisconsin it is
plain as day it is obvious to anybody
who's paid attention and this is gross
negligence to say something so stupid
when this is the highest profile case
we've had in in how long i don't know
at least since since since derrick
chauvin
yeah one year before that i don't know
not even a year oj rodney i mean this
this is a lot bigger than than chovin in
my opinion oh for sure yeah the the the
people being glued to this
i've had people who are a little older
said it feels like oj yeah everyone's
like glued to the tv weight oh
do you think the reason that it's a bit
more it's garnered so much more
attention is because the outcome was
less sure
i think it's because when
chauvin was after after chauvin you know
the video came out everyone like 90 of
people were on board with like get that
guy off the force yeah that was bad yeah
it's upsetting with with written house
the wright immediately saw the video and
said okay he was acting in self-defense
then the media lied and the left
immediately said we believe whatever the
tv tells us and so it became the the um
the necromancers of mainstream media
casting their spell over the over the
masses to keep them in the dark while
those of us who are out let's use the
allegory of the cave instead all of the
people sitting in the cave watching the
shadow puppets dance we were the people
who exited the cave and saw reality and
were desperately yelling to them that's
not true come out and they would be like
no
and so what i think made this so big
was how ingrained the lies were it took
anna kasparian a year
to finally realize the truth how did she
find out
she watched the video i think yeah i
think so too i think it's really
important for people like anna kasparian
to show publicly that they can change
their minds i think that that is such a
powerful example but look at the people
to see look at jenk yuger you know i
really doubling down talking about this
guy but you know he was he he said nasty
things about you know we brought him up
when we did the show with rogan and then
it became a stupid thing because the
media is so dumb they're like here's a
story they're arguing but he was like
written house is bad blah blah blah and
um and and he tweeted about me and joe
said you know right now's fanboys and i
simply responded we were just citing
anna kasparian
that's right
and i i definitely when she came out and
corrected herself and changed her
opinion publicly i definitely refrained
from hopping on any kind of hate
bandwagon you know going towards her
just because i felt like it is so
important and it is actually rare for
people on both sides to really just be
like you know what
i was wrong got to reward that you're
talking about talking about suing and
stuff tim can we talk about what kyle
does next
what does he do next well so
when is that when i saw that nick
sandman thing right and you see this kid
who's been through a lot but you kind of
it was you didn't see his suffering so
much and then he gets this huge payout
you think this guy doesn't need to work
for the rest of his life we don't know
what his payout is okay well yeah small
it was a private it could be
really yeah so so with uh the covington
kids for those that don't know the
context this is the kid who was standing
on the steps of the lincoln memorial
when uh the native american guy walked
up and started banging the drum in his
face the media lied and claimed it was
the other way around sandman sued a
bunch of media outlets the lawsuits were
for huge sums but they settled for an
undisclosed sum out of court some have
argued it's called uh he received a
nuisance fee meaning that
the media outlet probably just said look
we'll give you a hundred grand how does
that sound go away really it could have
been that so okay some people said it
could have been as small as 25 000. okay
so let's say that it's any amount of
money right and it could be as big as
you want i think it was big okay so
let's say that it's 10 million let's say
it's 50 million say whatever you want
not that big yeah okay but i thought
looking at that situation i reckon he's
ended up netting in a positive there
yeah he's had a year of uncomfortable
stuff and so on and so forth the
difference is seeing kyle's response
which i've found really uncomfortable
seeing him shaking he nearly faints
falls down to the floor you see him put
the bottle of water up to his mouth and
he can barely drink it and at that
moment i thought i wouldn't go through
what he's gone through even if i never
had to work 100 million
no way there is no amount of money
that would make that
trauma worthwhile the president of the
united states called him a white
supremacist
when
it was before he was president but still
you know
he made a video that showed a bunch of
crazy stuff like charlottesville and
then it also shows cal rittenhouse and
he's like the president won't denounce
white supremacy yeah i mean uh who is it
corey bush yes if she's doubling down oh
yeah is i isn't ayanna presley as well i
didn't see keith oberman keith obama
he came and asked for the poster
temporarily posted and then deleted did
you turn up my mic linda i hear you no
you're really loud
good uh people are saying i'm too low
are they okay
no
slowly crescendo but keith olbermann
also there's there's uh images going
around of him apparently tweeting
f this murderer and then uh deleting it
so i've seen that from multiple sources
being talked about online right now but
that's this is more than just doubling
down this is just hatred this is just
anger being directed at kyle again when
when clearly i mean this man was put on
trial and then and
i want to clear yeah i got to clarify
something too like look i know you know
i mentioned i mentioned just just before
that andrew branca said juror 54 was
probably an entitled karen or whatever i
i want to stop and say my respect my
compliments my utmost respect to juror
54.
you're 54 said not guilty
on all accounts yep so if this is the
case of someone who is viewed as a mask
karen or snooty leftist or whatever it
may actually just be someone who said
i'm not familiar with this and i'm going
to go through this thoroughly because i
refuse to to take this lightly and say
whatever you want maybe she is maybe she
is karen maybe she is whatever at the
end all that matters is this juror said
not guilty on all counts and we should
all be be respecting and um
congratulations
give me a good word congratulatory
grateful congratulatory appreciate you
should be grateful i appreciate it i
appreciate it and respectfully to all
the jurors who said
this is justice right so i think
i'd love to hear their story yeah we
don't know what they really have been
through yeah we know a little bit with
the msnbc stuff and
there's probably a lot more yeah and
some of them were saying you know the
media coverage has been uh scary and i
have known authoritative ladies have
been like i need the full details i i
just need all the information before i
move forward i don't think there's
anything wrong with that if you want to
be the kind of person who speaks to a
manager fine if you get to the root of
an issue and you come up with the
correct perspective i think that's great
it's possible that there are multiple
jurors that were thinking like okay i
think he's guilty and she was like the
voice of the jury and was saying okay
you think that i'm gonna hold this in
place until we can find a so she was
mediating well here's the worst here's
the worst thing with every with with you
know the analysis from bronco and with
what we said already that mask karen
snooty entitled what if
11 jurors said i don't want to do this i
don't want to be involved not i just say
he's guilty so i don't get in trouble
and juror 54 was the one going no he's
innocent no absolutely not yeah i would
love to see what if they don't record
that right they don't record the no no
jerry rooms have you noticed that during
the derek chauvin trial there was a lot
of pressure from social media onto the
jury you must find this man guilty yeah
we haven't really seen or at least i
haven't seen that same pressure with
regards to the jury itself
they were outside the courtroom
screaming and bull horning yeah they
were saying we're to burn it down that
was the experience they had to black out
the windows of the bus as the juries
were coming through so that they
couldn't see what was happening but they
could hear it msnbc was following them
down is that the same sort of
intimidation
targeted intimidation
way
a journalist so someone was caught
filming the jury and the judge said at
bus pickup there was someone filming it
the bailiff instructed them to delete
the footage or the deputy whoever and
we'll make sure this doesn't happen
again so everyone knew stay away from
the jury the jury's bus windows were
blacked out because they had to protect
them and then msnbc sent a reporter to
trail the bus to such a degree he was
blowing through stop lights and the
police pulled him over tweeted they
thought he was trying to get photos of
the jury this is a direct threat
from the courtroom that's right this
says there's people they hadn't happened
i mean in the shelving trial they were
being escorted into the building with
armed police and with rifles right
yeah i mean there are tweets all over
social media saying the most heinous
things that people would like to do to
the jury to the judge obviously to kyle
and obviously to anyone who thinks the
verdict was correct today so yeah they
went through a lot there's people making
open threats against the jury which you
would think the doj would get involved
in and start investigating and start
actually you know doing their job as a
part of the doj so that's why this this
this latest development that the doj
will be reviewing this potentially uh on
beheads of this congressman is a little
bit worrying because legally they have
no room here but that hasn't stopped
them before when you look at the actions
of the doj they're becoming more and
more aggressively politic political
they're becoming more and more
egregious in their actions so this to me
is something to of course
look at because it wouldn't it wouldn't
surprise me if they did to do something
from here in my own personal opinion can
you just think for a moment what would
have happened that night if kyle
rittenhouse hadn't shot if he hadn't
fired a single round that night what
would have occurred rosenbaum would have
had an ar he would have taken it from
him yeah i think he would have i i do
believe he would have killed kyle oh for
sure
yeah yeah but here's what so i talked
about this other night i think
on the surface rosenbaum was not going
to take a gun and randomly shoot people
but what they said was kyle said if he
got my gun he would have shot me and he
shot others and kyle's correct for one
reason you can't approach it from the
perspective that rosenbaum was just a
crazy guy who's going to run into a
crowd rosenbaum would have grabbed the
gun from kyle and probably used it on
him i certainly think so he threatened
to kill him already once he did
everyone would have screamed yo we shot
that guy he shot that guy get him get
him rosenbaum would then
oh god it's like passing the book yeah
yeah wow
i i it's a fair assessment right they
would have seen rosenbaum the same way
they saw kyle and yelled get him cranium
that boy and rosenbaum would have been
like no
crazy violent and he had a gun
now you know i think the biggest mistake
of the defense was they won so it's fine
but richards the defense lawyer in the
closing argument said that he was glad
that uh kyle rittenhouse shot those men
and i was like
yeah
see even even with us it's like
obviously the title of this video was
like you know has the word party in it
or whatever but like i don't think
anyone truly is like excited that any of
this happened there's not many winners
here well there's no one in this room
yeah not there there are certainly
people who
are happy
i think the whole thing was a net
negative across the board yeah the
reason we're happy is that kyle
rittenhouse's life will will not be
destroyed by this because of the tragic
nights of that uh tragic events of that
night um and from all the pain and
suffering and the torment he's gone
through he may actually get some
positive results here mandatory life
sentence i know that's what he was up
against and also we also have to at some
point talk about like
he will live with this forever i mean
i've never taken a life obviously i
don't think anyone in this rv has but
that has got to just be such a uniquely
traumatizing thing that's going to
affect him for the rest of his life you
know i mean this is just the beginning
so what happened today was right i also
think that they're actually i don't
think it's an entirely net negative
because i think it did set a precedent
that americans are allowed to defend
themselves against violent militias no i
i do think it's a net negative yeah i've
heard people have i i was talking about
this a little bit earlier and i said it
was always supposed to be our right to
defend ourselves of course the second
amendment was always supposed to be and
i think the fact that it was put on
trial was dragging all of us down that
being said we're happy because our
rights were upheld cal written house his
rights were upheld again
it's a tragic situation but it's it's
this simple
when richard said he was glad he said he
was glad that that ringhouse kyle shot
those men because if he didn't kyle
would have would have died
i wouldn't say that i think that's
terrible um you know glad someone was
shot it's just it's simple to say
that it's unfortunate he had to do this
but you need to understand as much as
this whole night was a tragedy kyle
rittenhouse is not responsible for it he
was attacked by three assailants
one overtly and violently and two
seemingly mindlessly and violently and
in each instance he had a right to
defend himself and the jury agreed
where it may be a net negative which
means the totality comes out below zero
but i agree with you blair that i think
something positive within that negative
is that if people are considering going
out and burning buildings down and there
are militia there to defend it with that
are armed don't attack them
those people are there for a reason to
with weapons for a reason it's not a
show it's not a video game
and perhaps people you know for better
or for worse may think twice about going
out and burning down their local mom and
pop shop now i do think this is a a good
precedent in that regard and another
thing that i think we haven't really
fully sussed out is that this is i would
say this is very much a red pill for
people who have kind of engaged with it
for like the lady who was saying you
know i'm pretty well read i'm pretty
liberal i'm i'm fully educated or
whatever i did not know this now i know
this her comments were full of people
saying you know i didn't know that
either i think that's great it's a white
pill for us it's a red pill for them
because it's like yeah look what the
news is saying when you can it's like
trump's speech like you can watch a
speech and then you can watch what
they're saying about it you can watch
the video and then you can watch what
the media is saying about kyle
rittenhouse and you're like these two
things are not the same this doesn't add
up yeah if nothing else it needs to
teach people that
corporate media is the enemy exactly
they have always currently are and will
always lie to you and they want blood
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you